America has the biggest immigration
population in the world the country has
long attracted people in search of a
better life
among them are Cambodian migrants who
fled war and genocide at home and have
found an unlikely route to prosperity
doughnuts
it's 4:40 a.m. and most people in this
city are still fast asleep but when Los
Angeles wakes up Theresa tango needs to
be ready she's the co-owner of Blinky's
donut Emporium as soon as I get in I
threw all my stuff aside and I start
packing her boxes
I feel like it's a contest every day I'm
just trying to beat myself so every day
is very different is this when we sell a
few hundred this days when we sell a few
hundred boxes these days that we sell
thousands of donuts Teresa and her dad
he bought Blinky's in 2003 that is very
delicate what he's doing he treats them
like they're his babies I don't think it
was that gentle with me growing up but
he's definitely a lot like he was a lot
TLC in his donuts working with my dad
this pros and cons I mean he's gonna be
my boss regardless even though I think
I'm the boss he still thinks he's the
boss but we do have a great relationship
and I'm blessed to be able to work with
my dad every day you like working with
me
no comment making donuts is a long way
from where Hugh started out his life so
my parents escaped Cambodia during the
Khmer Rouge in 1979 early 1980s it was a
genocide it was a tol genocide where we
lost a lot of family members they were
lucky enough to be able to immigrate to
France and they were there for 20 years
but in a cruel twist of fate Teresa's
family was subjected to a violent attack
we had to leave unfortunately because my
friends were again victims of an attack
where we were robbed at gunpoint and my
parents were beaten they didn't feel
safe living in France anymore so they
moved to LA arriving in the USA was
another huge change for the ingo family
Ellie was a third new start for my
parents that was the third country in
their life and for me it was my second
one it was so different we didn't speak
the language we didn't know how to drive
here so everything was new between 1975
and 1994 nearly 160,000 Cambodians were
admitted to America as refugees one of
them was Ted and [ __ ] he became known as
the donut King the entrepreneur made his
fortune through a chain of stores by the
mid 90s inspired by mr. enjoys success
there were as many as 2,400 Cambodian
owned donut shops in Southern California
la was everything California was
everything so it was just like a dream
come true just to be able to be here
so I never thought I would be the owner
your donut shop I thought it was just
gonna be a stepping stone for me but
because of the connection we've made
with our customers and the community now
it just makes it whole I love that it's
a total neighborhood community donut
shop I know the owners the owners don't
like kids Los Angeles has a reputation
for healthy eating but that hasn't
slowed the steady stream of patrons at
Blinky's donuts are bulletproof they're
what makes your happy
the little go-to snack that you know you
can have on cheat day we have a lot of
bodybuilders that come in they have a
lot of moms are super healthy but they
still bring their kids for that they'll
touch of sugar it doesn't matter how
healthy the craze is you're still gonna
want to donate at the end of the day
[Music]
blinkie's is now one of the top-rated
donut shops in Los Angeles for me blink
uses everything about the American dream
it's not a big dream I'm not you know
driving Rolls Royces or anything like
that but I'm living the dream I'm here
I'm safe I'm selling an American product
I'm making an American product for the
Americans so yeah it's a it's a blessing
it's a privilege for me
[Music]